[موسيقى]
رد فعل الأشخاص على الحانات على سبيل
المثال عندما يدخلون يكونون
ضائعين بعض الشيء، لذا فأنت بحاجة حقًا إلى إرشادهم،
لذلك دعونا نبدأ من Whisky Bar حيث
لديك بعض أنواع الويسكي الفريدة التي
تأتي من أنواع مختلفة من البلدان
النادل  سيكون
معلمك المفضل عبر تاريخ الويسكي
عندما تأتي إلى تيكي، كل شيء يدور
حول المنحدرات المتعلقة بالطبول القديمة.
أود أن أقول إنها تشبه الحانة الحية
لأنها تشبه كل شيء يتعلق
بالنار وذاكرة الوصول العشوائي في التاريخ الماضي
هناك  كان القراصنة يستخدمونه، لذا فإن
كل شيء يشبه نوعًا من مشروب الكانبان
وكوكتيلات الشمبانيا، فهم أكثر شمبانيًا وأكثر
تألقًا بالطبع، فهو
قادم من فرنسا
بمجرد وصولك إلى جين فودكا، لذا فهو
مثل بار متصل جيدًا
لأنه  محرك الفودكا هو في الأساس
أكثر المشروبات الروحية التي تشرب في جميع أنحاء العالم هناك
نلعب قليلاً مع الخضار والفواكه
[موسيقى]
لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى المكسيك ولكن المكسيك تأتي
إليك هذه التكيلا تتطابق أكثر
مع البرتقال مع الليمون مع الليمون
مع الملح مع  السكر، لذا
يمكنك إقران كل هذا النوع من الأذواق،
ثم لدينا ميزكال أيضًا وهو
مفتاح صغير ويستخدم بشكل أساسي
لأغراض الكوكتيل وليس للقطات
من ذلك الجزء الذي سنتناوله في
مطبخ نيكاي  المطعم الذي قمنا ببنائه على
الجانب الآخر، يوجد لدينا بار ساكي، لذلك
لدينا محطة Live Sushi جنبًا إلى جنب
مع محطة الساكي،
ثم ننتقل إلى
بار النبيذ، وهو أكثر لمحبي النبيذ، كل شيء
يتعلق بالزجاج المختلف
والمنطقة المختلفة، دعنا  قل نبيذ العالم القديم الجديد،
لذا فهو حقًا ذو
خبرة حقًا ويمكن أن يتطابق أيضًا مع
الطعام
بمجرد أن يجلس الناس في المطعم،
لا نريدهم أن يبقوا هناك، نريدهم
أن يتجولوا، ستذهب مثل
السائحين  إلى الشوارع